[Musique]
bon alors est maintenant qu en bon
français vous avez suivi les annonces
que vous avez acheté un plateau de
fromages et qui vous en reste des tas de
petits bouts qu'est ce que vous en
faites
qu'est ce que vous en feriez si j'étais
pas là pour avec ça vous faire un
superbe fromage fondu parce que sinon
vous savez dans le sud ouest
ma tante germaine elle ne perdez rien
alors avec ses morceaux de fromage qui
reste et qui était plus utilisable mais
table sur un plateau trop sec
avec tous ces fromages à pâte molle
comme le brie de coulommiers le
camembert
on faisait et ont fait un super bon
fromage fondu qu'on mange tiède est à
l'essai des tranches de pain grillé de
pain de campagne avec une petite pointe
d'ail 2 si les enfants
un régal alors qu'est ce qu'il faut pour
ça eh bien il faut une belle cuillère à
soupe de beurre un peu de sel un peu de
poires inverse et demi c'est à dire 32
cm de neige cru je vous ai déjà dit
pourquoi leur lait cru il nous faut
trois cuillères à soupe de farine qui a
été tamisée pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
grumeaux
et puis environ 350 grammes à 400
grammes moi aujourd'hui j'ai des bouts
de briques bien sûr c'est normal et du
colomiers et puis bien sûr le pain de
campagne est là et l'ail pour tout à
l'heure alors le voyez le jeune ait
commencé tout simplement pas reprendre
mes morceaux de fromage donc 350 à 400
grammes
je vais enlever largement la peau parce
que ces salaires et des cetc pas qu'il
soit mauvais mais ça a laissé des taches
noires après dans cet hommage monde qui
sont pas mal et et puis ces morceaux
bien les préparer les couper en lamelles
et les mettre dans une assiette
je continue avec un peu colomiers arrêts
alors ça y est voilà mes 350 grammes de
fromage sont coupés je vous ai donc dit
qu'il y avait du brie de coulommiers on
peut y mettre du camembert et vous avez
vous pouvez garder ses petits boulots
fromage d'une semaine sur l'autre même
s'ils sont secs
ça marche très très bien donc vous ne
pouvez plus rien à perdre alors ils sont
coupés et puis là j'ai ma farine alors
j'en mets trois clients à soupe dans un
pub saladier et je remplis un verre de
lait ce sont des verts qui font 20
centilitres pile il m'en faut un verre
et demi donc tendre centilitres et petit
à petit j'incorpore avec un fouet le
lait c'est pas facile mais vous
arriverez pas mais comment à la raison
un petit à petit vous incorporez la
farine au lait pour obtenir si possible
il n'arrive pas souvent une patte
absolument sans renier en verre et un
demi-verre encore donc 35 titres
je laisse le fourneau reste on aura
besoin de remuer juste avant de
l'ajouter dans la cocotte alors notre
côté parce qu'on pose sur feu doux ça
c'est très important
on y ajoute une belle cuillère à soupe
de beurre et aussitôt que le beurre
commence à fondre
on devra ajouter nos petits morceaux de
forage dans le bain réforme du seuil et
les justes mousseux et là on ajoute
toutes nos lamelles de fromage c'est
important d'aller assez vite plus vite
que je ne le fais derrière et puis
aussitôt qu'on aura les coûts de ces
lamelles de fromage de danse avec la
fourchette on va écraser dans la cocotte
pour obtenir une allée voir une belle
pâte bien homogène pour que ce soit sur
feu très doux
c'est capital sinon ça poserait des
problèmes vers les autres fromages
fondre de suite et donc une minute je
vais continuer à malaxer on aura une
superbe pathogènes dans laquelle on va
rajouter petit à petit notre lait dans
lequel on a mis la table
bon mais ça fait voyez deux minutes que
je vous nous regardez cette pâte siens
et même s'il est homogène alors là je
vais prendre le bol qui détient le lait
et la famille de normes inutile de vous
dire que j'ai prix du lait cru vincennes
le savez je vous ai déjà dit pourquoi je
ne voulais pas de lait pasteurisé parce
qu'on perd tout le goût du lait j'ajoute
je mets environ le quart du lait je
mélange est aussitôt au collet est
important voyez ça va très vite
j'ajoute deuxième cas
ça s'incorpore très vite le troisième
c'est une recette très rapide voyez ça
se mélange tout de suite
et puis le quatrième cas jusqu'au fond
et là tout de suite je vais monter le
feu un petit peu parce qu'elle voit là
il faut que nous arrivions aura de
l'ébullition de façon à ce que la farine
elles deviennent un peu plus compact et
face de ce fromage qui pour l'instant
liquide une pâte qui devient très bien
et qui est d'ailleurs de plus en plus
compacts quand elle devient tiède et
froide
là je goûte avec le doigt bien sûr que
nous reconnaissait il était sale et ce
moyen est alors le poivre sur george
bush ont été reçus par de mauvaises lois
et là on va laisser sur le feu sans
affecter de remuer pendant deux minutes
jusqu'à ce qu'on prenne une consistance
vous le verrez qui ressemble un peu à du
viande 1 dans deux minutes voir ailleurs
des biens l'accord si ce temps soyez et
je vous dise ce fromage là encore un peu
épaissir quand ils se croient et là tout
de suite mais tout de suite vous la
verser dans le gobelin faut pas traîner
voyez ça abonde c'est ce qu'on est bon
chez nous une recette et qui abondent
lagement et là maintenant regardez moi
si c'est beau juste à côté vous avez ce
pain grillé pour la légèrement aillés je
peux pas résister je veux en faire une
tartine a tout de suite même chaud
vous conseille de l'essayer de ce soir
[Musique]